hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
with less than three weeks until
election day and millions of americans
already casting their ballots president
trump and democratic presidential
nominee joe biden
are hitting key battleground states
courting voters in pennsylvania and
florida
mark lotter director of strategic
communications for the trump campaign
discusses president trump's return to
the campaign trail the ongoing supreme
court confirmation hearings
and discussion over the fate of the
affordable care act
and in most states across the u.s the
number of coronavirus cases continues to
rise
fox news senior meteorologist janice
dean opens up
about losing her in-laws to the virus in
a new york nursing home earlier this
year
and why she believes their deaths could
have been avoided
plus commentary by fox news medical
contributor dr nicole sapphire
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe on
your favorite podcast player
by going to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm jerry willis i'm steve ducey i'm
shannon breme and this is the fox news
rundown
wednesday october 14 2020 i'm jessica
rosenthal
with less than three weeks to go until
election day it's not just a campaign
that's dominating
but a supreme court confirmation hearing
focused on abortion
gay marriage and especially health care
the president has already signed the
executive order which would provide
protections for people with pre-existing
conditions and and so that protection
will continue
i'm dave anthony why are we talking to a
meteorologist
about the coronavirus because fox's
janisteen
lost two in-laws in new york nursing
homes and is searching
for answers i am the weather person and
i've never
been a political person this has nothing
to do with politics this is
personal this is my family i need to
know answers for my
family and i'm dr nicole sapphire i've
got the final word on the fox news
rundown
campaigning continues with less than
three weeks to go before election day
but another big focus has been the
senate's supreme court confirmation
hearing for judge amy coney barrett
dominating the airwaves and social media
while the democratic nominee for
president joe biden was talking to
seniors in florida
and the president was getting ready for
a rally in pennsylvania barrett
was being sometimes praised and thanked
by republicans on tuesday and questioned
and criticized by democrats
the focus on roe versus wade and gay
marriage
and of course health care this guy
our president he is the one that decided
to plop a supreme court nomination in
the middle of an election
when people's health care is on the line
with the case before
the court on november 10th minnesota
democratic senator amy klobuchar said
the president wrote on twitter that it
would be a
big win to have a supreme court that
would strike down the health law
a day before he nominated barrett
barrett said she couldn't comment on the
president's twitter but
no one has elicited from me any
commitment in a case or even brought up
a commitment in the case
i am a hundred 100 committed to judicial
independence from political pressure
so whatever people's you know party
platforms may be or campaign promises
maybe the reason why
judges have life tenure is to insulate
them from those
pressures while it appears republicans
have enough votes to confirm barrett
others like rhode island democrat
sheldon whitehouse spoke at length
without asking barrett a single question
you can tell that their strategy is to
basically just make speeches and not
actually hear from the nominee which
just actually shows you
that the democrats have no intention of
actually giving her a fair hearing
mark lotter is the director of strategic
communications for the trump campaign
they're just going to come out and
they're going to vote no in math
which is really which is really a shame
you've even seen
some uh some liberal commentators uh on
on national media say that this is
you know in normal times she would she
would absolutely sail through in a
bipartisan
uh fashion but because we find ourselves
where we are with this democrat party
that has
no interest in working with president
trump on anything
uh it's going to be a straight
party-line vote democrats have
have really expressed their fears about
amy coney barrett's uh possible decision
on the aca in particular
because they they note that she wrote in
2017
um that in her mind chief justice
roberts pushed the aca beyond
its plausible meaning um during these
hearings
we have heard from the president he's
been tweeting and he wrote
we will have health care which is far
better than obamacare
at a far lower cost big premium
reduction
people with pre-existing conditions will
be protected
when will we hear more about a specific
health care plan from the president i
i know he signed the america first
health care plan last month right but
as his own tweet indicates there is a
lot more to address when it comes to
health care
well first and foremost we have to see
obviously how the court rules uh there
is there is a
a case that will be heard after the
election uh in the supreme court uh on
the aca
uh but ultimately the president has been
saying this from the very beginning you
know the
a government program is not the answer
we were lied to by the obama biden
administration when they said that you
could keep your plan if you wanted to
you could keep your doctor if you wanted
to
and we saw premium skyrocket as as as
employers as health care companies
pulled out of the private sector market
and competition
and basically the government just
stepped in what you see
under the president is a multi-faceted
approach
you see not only a focus on lowering
prescription drug prices which we have
seen the prices
drop you've also seen the president want
to expand
private options for people to get health
insurance i mean there's no reason
why small businesses shouldn't be able
to pool their resources together
and try to get the same kind of big
buying power that a major company could
which lowers health care costs it lowers
the risk for the insurance companies but
that's something that the aca
threw out and so what we need to do is
get those association health care plans
back into
back into operation i remember but
before the aca
where i was in my home state of indiana
the chamber used to of commerce used to
have what they called chamber care
and so they had a lot of companies that
were actually joining the chamber
just so they could have whether they
were a small law firm or a small florist
or a baker
so they could get access to that and
provide health care
to their employees it's something we can
get back to
it's one facet of things that we can get
back to but you've already seen the
president lay the building blocks out of
this and we just need to continue to
build on it
and get the aca out of the way how do
you protect people with pre-existing
conditions if the supreme court were to
rule that the aca is unconstitutional if
the supreme court says okay
fine this is we agree it's
unconstitutional goodbye
um you know the the fear is millions
would
would lose their health care what's the
answer what's even the interim
answer to those well the president is
already the president has already signed
the executive order which would provide
protections for people with pre-existing
conditions and and so that protection
will continue whether the aca
is is thrown out or not that protection
is absolutely rock solid
and it's something that the president
would continue let's talk about kovid
for a second um the president's white
house doctor has said he is not
infectious
that he he beat this thing um that he
has tested negative on consecutive days
and as we know back on the campaign
trail he's rallies planned for the whole
week
um how has in in your opinion
how has his own battle with kovid
reshaped things if at all because like
in florida on monday for example
we didn't see this like big push or an
insistence on
distancing or or mask wearing for rally
goers
well we always provide we always provide
masks and hand sanitizer and things
at these rallies and we encourage people
to wear them we also believe
though fundamentally that the american
people should be trusted with their
own with their own health care choices
for folks who
would find themselves in a high risk
category where they may have a negative
outcome
from covid we absolutely encourage them
to wear a mask socially distanced
and to be honest with you they should
probably not be coming to a rally
but for the rest of us it's something
that we can manage and that we've got to
get to this place where we can be
safe be healthy protect the vulnerable
but also get back to work get back to
school get back to life
will we ever learn more mark about when
he last tested negative before
contracting covid
uh that's something that would be
handled by the white house and and the
white house doctors
uh so you know obviously that'd be a
question to be best addressed by them
it's great to see the president has
actually tested twice negative now he's
back out on the campaign trail
and really when you think about it in
the course of one week
he went from being admitted to the
hospital and and given these treatments
to now fully recovered fully clear and
fully up to work
i mean that that just shows you the
great work that's being done by doctors
and nurses
and the people in the labs who are
developing these
these great therapeutics uh that can
literally
as the president has said turn around
how he was feeling
in one day um i know that the president
and his supporters dismiss
a lot of polling um and they say that
you know most polls oversample democrats
but
we we are looking at polling data right
it's what we have in swing states biden
is doing better than the president
um in the real clear politics average of
polls i think in pennsylvania
he's up seven points florida three
michigan seven wisconsin six
what's the strategy for the next three
weeks
um our rallies in swing states you know
enough to pull back for example
you know suburban women or or something
else needed other than just
you know the the high intensity rally
pitch
in all of the swing states well i mean
the first thing i would say is even an
average of bad poles are
is an average of bad poles uh you know
these poles are so methodically flawed
uh that they're they're actually
laughable uh you know our data which was
right in 2016
uh and i believe will be right and
proven right again in 2020 shows that
the president is ahead of where he was
in 2016 and that we are basically
either ahead or right where we need to
be in
all of the battleground states that get
the president to 270
and then add on the fact that we have
the largest grassroots
army of volunteers of any presidential
campaign in history we have 2.4 million
trained volunteers that's even more than
barack obama had in 2012.
they're out there hitting the doors
they're making phone calls they're going
to make sure
people get out to vote and there's also
a huge enthusiasm
amongst republicans and people who love
this president
to get out and vote so we have all of
that at our
at our backs uh the wind in our sails so
to speak
talk to me about the decision to cancel
this next debate
uh you know why why miss the opportunity
to
to fight it out right we know this
president is known for liking to to duke
it out you know why walk and is it just
because it's a virtual debate is that
the only reason
well i think you'd have to ask the
presidential debate commission on why
they canceled it i mean the i the fact
that they actually went to a virtual
debate
a week before the debate when there was
still plenty of time for a the president
to test negative twice which he has now
since
done uh to show that he is not going to
transmit it
that you could do social distancing and
other factors like they did during the
vice presidential debate i mean they had
them
12 feet apart from each other and yet
still the democrats were insisting on
on basically you know surrounding kamala
harris in in plexiglas
so you could have done a lot of other
things but they didn't choose to
negotiate
they just made a decision to make this
thing a zoom call
and this is a town hall this is not a
this is not a
just two candidates going back and forth
with a moderator
this is interacting with the actual
voters and i just don't think that you
can get that kind of a town hall
feel for what the voters are talking
about for what the candidates are doing
when you're sitting in you know in these
you know in these
studios and then also we've got a very
real concern i mean who's going to stand
outside the door to joe's biden's
basement
and make sure that no one comes in with
notes or is putting up words on his
teleprompter
or whispering the answers in his ear you
know
there are lots of issues with this
format that was thrown on
with no debate no discussion amongst the
candidates
it literally just got rushed out the
door the morning after
vice president pence took kamala harris
to school
mark finally joe biden has been saying
on the campaign trail
that donald trump did not learn his
lesson from kovid that he's just doubled
down
and says uses the word negligence and
says that the president's
attitude has been reckless and has
actually
led to covet deaths that people are
missing from dining room tables
because of this president what do you
guys say to that i mean that's a
shameful
politician politicization of this
pandemic which is something i have come
to expect from the democrats
who really would rather just score cheap
political points than actually do
something positive
and you know i wish joe biden would show
half of the outrage
against china where this virus actually
came from
but he is a man so beholden and weak to
china
you know he called the president
xenophobic and racist for closing down
travel from china which dr fauci said
saved lives
you know he has come up with plans that
are nothing more than what the president
has already done
i mean we know joe biden is a plagiarist
he's doing it again
and now he's just a political plagiarist
because he's just
basically saying things the president's
already doing
and trying and trying to score political
points from it and i think it's
disgraceful what he's done
mark loner uh with the trump campaign
thank you so much for your time
absolutely thank you
this is dr nicole sapphire with your fox
news commentary coming up
when the coronavirus outbreak turned
into a pandemic
new york's governor stood out as his
state was hit the hardest
we're still in the woods for days and
days andrew cuomo was on tv with his
charts and power points
good news is great news in my opinion we
can control the spread
the democrats news conferences were
covered nearly as much as the white
house coronavirus task force
older people vulnerable people
are going to die from this virus
that is going to happen despite whatever
you do
over 33 000 people have died in new york
that's more than double any other state
nearly 6 700 of them died in nursing
homes and adult care facilities
an advisory governor cuomo issued in
march is still getting a lot of scrutiny
it directed nursing homes must comply
with the expedited receipt of residents
released from hospitals
to address the urgent need for beds for
covid patients
it also in text underlined directed no
resident should be denied
entry into a nursing home because they
have the coronavirus or are suspected of
having it
cuomo critics say that led to the spread
of covet in nursing homes
and they claim he undercounts the number
by not including those who died after
being sent to hospitals
both my husband's parents died and they
were in separate elder care facilities
janis dean is fox's senior meteorologist
his dad was in a nursing home he was
trying to get better
he had dementia but he had some health
issues and the plan was we were supposed
to have him in
the assisted living residence which was
close to our home
where both his parents could be in you
know a double room
uh it was a great little arrangement
that we had both of his parents needed
to be looked after
and i mean just weeks after
they were put in their respective elder
care facilities covid
happened we were on quarantine we
couldn't go see them
we had to rely on you know the the
people that were
at the nursing home and the assisted
living residents to be
our eyes and ears because we couldn't be
there
and we get a call on uh saturday morning
in late march
that his dad wasn't feeling well and
this is the first we had heard that he
wasn't feeling well
okay now did you immediately think
coronavirus at the time
no we didn't i mean listen it was late
in march we knew
that everything was on lockdown we also
knew that
um that the elderly were were more
susceptible
but we hadn't heard that his dad wasn't
doing well so
and we didn't know about the governor's
mandate of putting coveted positive
patients into nursing homes now i do
remember
shortly before he got sick we didn't get
a call from his nursing home
saying that he was going to be moved to
another floor to allow for
additional patients to come into the
nursing home
and so when i look back on that phone
call i believe
that was because they were bringing
covert patients into his nursing home
all right um so his condition then
worsened over the
week or two well no we got the phone
call
saturday morning that he wasn't feeling
well and three hours later we get the
phone call
that he's dead what so we had no lead-up
time whatsoever
none wow what a shock
total shock and they told us to
call a funeral home and that whole
series of events during the time where
his dad had died and then
we had to tell his mom and then his mom
had died
is like a nightmare i mean so for his
mom we were nervous
because we you know we didn't want her
to get sick and then she
did get sick and we were scared for her
to go to the hospital because at the
time we didn't know she had covered
and we were saying dee we don't want you
to go to the hospital because we're
afraid if you go to the hospital you're
gonna get covered so
um but as it turned out she had to go
and she was diagnosed
with coven when she went to the hospital
and she died shortly after that
when was that when did she get sick and
how long after
after your father-in-law died was that
it was it was around two weeks because i
remember it was just before easter
because the last time my husband talked
to his mom she wanted us to get easter
presents for the kids
and put her name on it so she died
uh short she got sick shortly after that
and died a few days afterwards
but one of the reasons why i am vocal is
is well there's many reasons obviously
with the governor and the and the
mandate for
the coveted patients to go into nursing
homes that was in place for 46 days
the other reason is we don't have a
count of a
solid number of deaths that happened
in the hospitals like my mother-in-law
governor cuomo
is the only governor that will not count
the coveted cases that came from the
nursing homes or the elder care
facilities that died in the hospital
and he refuses to give us those numbers
so he when he goes on television
and gives these weird updates of
percentages of how many people
died in nursing homes he's not being
truthful because we don't have the
number
that had covid that died in the
hospitals like my mother-in-law and some
of those
numbers are double what the reports are
right now over the summer janisteen took
her concerns
to state lawmakers in albany new york i
didn't know i would ever be in this
position
but when i started listening to the news
reports and not hearing the questions
being asked
i felt it was important because i have a
platform
to start raising those questions on my
own that is from state senator james
tadisco's facebook but
janice almost didn't get to testify they
were having hearings in august
and i asked to tell my story
uh be a witness at these hearings that
were held virtually
in two weeks in august and i was
supposed to be
able to testify on one of the weeks
um and i was told that i was going to
get proper invite on a friday
and the testimony would be on the
following monday i never got the invite
and over the weekend i texted my friend
councilman joe borelli who was the one
who
kind of helped orchestrate the um the
testimony
and he said that they didn't want me to
testify
uh that they you know the quote was they
were
um uncomfortable with my story
um so with your story because you're a
a you know high profile person at fox or
your story because they don't believe
you what
i well i think it has to do with the
where i work um they were uncomfortable
because of
my affiliation with fox and my argument
it doesn't matter
and i am the weather person and i've
never been a political person this has
nothing to do with politics this is
personal this is my family
i need to know answers for my family
um so it got back
you know i was able to go on tucker
carlson that night
god bless tucker and i was able to you
know tell
the fox viewers and tucker my story that
i was supposed to testify and they
rescinded the invitation and then i got
a phone call and they said oh well we're
gonna make another
uh makeshift you know uh
zoom session for some of the people that
weren't able to testify
but you know my story didn't go on the
record
um it was just sort of a you know pat on
the head type of thing
we'll let you we'll let you speak in
front of a few um
republican lawmakers although
one of the democratic lawmakers
assemblyman kim did come on and ask a
question and actually assemblyman kim
has been very vocal about the nursing
home tragedy because he had a loved one
that was in a nursing home so
this is this needs to be bipartisan i i
don't care if you're republican or
democrat it
should affect everyone who has lost a
loved one in new york what is it you
want i want an independent bipartisan
investigation into the nursing home
tragedy in new york state
i do not want the governor to have the
last say
i would like you know lawmakers and
subpoenas
and people who are made to tell the
truth
to take the witness stand and to find
out answers
why did he have a mandate to place
coveted positive patients into nursing
homes for 46 days he's blamed everybody
else for that mandate
including god mother nature in new york
post he says it's political it's fox
fox news michael goodwin um
he's blamed everyone except the person
whose name
is on the order to place the covid
patients into nursing homes
and i want a real number i want to know
how many
people got covered in nursing homes
including the ones that died in the
hospital
i don't want him to have the last say i
would like lawmakers to
you know both republican and democratic
lawmakers
to be able to put people uh on the hot
seat and
and have the questions answered
including
the governor the governor did have an
investigation
into himself conducted by his
administration and of course it absolved
him
of all uh guilt so um
you know and his book is just another
it's for for grieving families
to see him on television and you know
saying that this is you know his
his leadership skills and how he crushed
the curve or
whatever he uses the the curve um
uh what does he say he says not crushed
the curve but he still
knows right yeah it was a big deal for a
long time
my relatives are on that curve you know
my my relatives are not
just statistics they're actual people
their names are mickey and
d newman and they are new york tough
they were new york tough like the
governor likes to call himself
and certainly they were tougher than the
governor is because he can't take any
criticism whatsoever
and and refuses to take any
responsibility for any of his poor
decisions
now governor cuomo has defended his
actions and that march advisory claiming
he was following federal cdc guidelines
and that advisory was amended in may to
only release hospital patients to
nursing homes
if they test negative but the new york
health department does say
6 300 people with covid were released
into nursing homes
however its investigation also found
more than 37
000 nursing home workers were infected
and they
unknowingly were the cause of the spread
of infection
and the governor told finger lakes news
in the end they always had hospital
capacity so
it never happened where we needed to say
to a nursing home
we need you to take this person even
though they are covet positive and he
repeated
it never happened right i remember
seeing that and just thinking to myself
and you completely erased my relatives
it never happened it did happen um
and you know does he need to see the
death certificates
that say covet on them i've said this
had he at the very beginning
said i made a mistake exactly what you
said i didn't think we're going to have
hospital beds i
had to make room for the overwhelming
amount of patients that were coming into
hospitals
i didn't know what to do i thought the
nursing homes could take
the patience i made a mistake had he
done that
at the very beginning we would not be
here we were in the middle of
the pandemic we didn't know how many
people
um were going to come down with this the
the numbers were
like way off but he never did
and now to see him being asked the
questions finally about the nursing
homes
and him like pretending that the
question never happened or
you know just rambling on about nonsense
uh the fact that he doesn't answer the
question speaks volumes now
what if he comes out in the future and
says you know what
i wish i hadn't done that and i'm sorry
that happened
i wish he would and dave i tell you i
don't think he will ever take any kind
of responsibility
unless we have an independent bipartisan
investigation with subpoena
power that makes him tell the truth
janisteen senior meteorologist at fox
news and on a crusade
in the nursing home deaths in new york
we thank you very much for joining us
thank you dave appreciate it
[Music]
from the fox news podcast network
download and listen to the untold story
with martha mccallum the host of the
story on fox news channel sits down with
major newsmakers each week to get their
untold story subscribe and listen now by
going to foxnewspodcasts.com
it's time for your fox news commentary
dr
nicole sapphire what's on your mind
well october is breast cancer awareness
month but october 2020 seems different
than any other october that i
a breast imaging specialist have
experienced in my lifetime
rather than seeing the pink insignia of
breast cancer awareness signs everywhere
the country continues to be in a state
of partial lockdown from the coven 19
pandemic
so of course this is very concerning to
me as someone who meets with breast
cancer patients in her daily practice
but the irony is more than 35 000 breast
cancer diagnoses can be delayed and an
additional
5200 women may die in the united states
over the next decade
because of delayed diagnoses and
treatment from the earlier pause and
care with lockdown
the covet 19 pandemic brought many
things to a screeching halt
including mammograms and most other
non-emergency
but necessary health care while sars
cov2 can pose a risk to your health
cancer does too so we can't trade one
for the other
as our country continues to reopen
health care providers nationwide are
resuming mammograms and other services
radiologists and other providers are
following cdc
and the american college of radiology
guidelines to protect patients
as they are re-offering cancer
screenings orthopedic exams and other
previously postponed care
for our part we have all been smart to
play it safe during the pandemic
however if you are a woman age 40 and
older being cautious now means talking
to your doctor about the mammogram
you've been putting off
or that was delayed by copit19 also if
you are a woman
or a man for that matter of any age with
a change in your body especially your
breasts
please don't put it off i have diagnosed
breast cancer in women
ages 18 to 99 and numerous men too
so don't kid yourself that the new lump
you are feeling is nothing to worry
about
please let your doctor decide if it
weren't further investigation
a doctor's office can pose some risk
however hospitals and physician
offices have stepped up sterilization
spread out appointment times to allow
fewer people on site
and taken many other steps to keep safe
as possible
so here are some tips to keep in mind
when rescheduling a mammogram
or any other needed health care ask your
doctor about coveted safety protocols so
you know what to expect when you get
there
discuss your individualized risks and
care plan with your provider team
especially if you are elderly
have chronic health issues or
immunocompromised
take your temperature and wash your
hands before leaving home
wear a mask to the appointment wear
gloves if necessary
and certainly avoid touching your face
your nose your eyes your mouth
try not to show up too early use
automatic doors when possible avoid
touching surfaces
and socially distance from others limit
those who go
with you to the appointment fewer people
on site limits your exposure and that of
others
and please allow more time offices are
spacing out appointments to thoroughly
disinfect rooms and equipment
we are all in this together visiting the
doctor may make you nervous
especially now i get it however not
rescheduling your mammogram
can allow cancers to remain hidden until
they are more advanced
and less treatable please do not let
that happen
pandemic or not mammography saves lives
as we continue in breast cancer
awareness month it's time to get back to
care
for our health for ourselves and our
families
this is dr nicole sapphire i'm a breast
imaging specialist at memorial sloan
kettering cancer center
author of make america healthy again and
fox news contributor
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
that's the perino and stir walt i'll
tell you what podcast
dana parino of the five and fox news
political editor chris stirewell dissect
the ins and outs of national politics
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes